Hey, Andy.
Hey, Conan.
How you holding up?
I'm actually going a
little insane, you know?
Me too, you know what
I really miss, sports.
I'm having serious sports withdrawal.
Wait, sports are canceled?
Yeah, of course sports are
canceled, they've been canceled
for a while now.
Oh, I haven't noticed.
Then I think we know what time it is Andy.
Let's do it!
It's time for Andy Richter's Sports Blast!
(upbeat music)
[Ghostly Voice] Andy
Richter's Sports Blast!
At home edition!
Welcome to Sports Blast!
Let's blast some sports!
[Ghostly Voice] Sports!
Hit me!
(ball hitting chest)
This is a super special
edition of Sports Blast,
because right now there are no sports!
[Ghostly Voice] Sports!
That means it's time for
our Sports Blast salute
to empty sports venues.
[Narrator] Salute to empty sports venues!
The Wimbledome!
Sports!
Okay Arena!
The Blunt Place!
Sports!
[Man] La Estadia de mucho mucho kicking!
[Ghostly Voice] Sports
[Man] The Fedex Taco
Bell Frito Lay Goodyear
House of Sponsorship Sports Complex!
[Ghostly Voice] Sports!
[Man] The Wisconsin Palace of Grunts!
[Man] And, Yale University's
Sadam Hussein Fieldhouse!
[Ghostly Voice] Sports!
Hey Andy, I'm open!
Okay!
(catching ball)
(laughing) Good throw!
(horn)
That means it's time for
Sports Blast correspondent
Conan O'Brien to give us some
classic baseball highlights!
[Ghostly Voice] Conan's
World Series Recap!
Hey, classic sports are
all the rage right now,
so here's a play by play
of the last two innings
of Game five of the 2017 World Series.
Walk!
Sports!
Strike out!
Home run!
Sports!
Double!
[Narrator] Sports!
Groundout!
Sports!
Single!
Line out!
Sports!
Fly out!
Foul out!
Sports!
Double!
Fly out!
Sports!
Line out!
Single!
Sports!
Fly out!
Ground out!
Sports!
Strike out!
Hit by a pit, single!
Sports!
And that's the game.
Back to you, Andy!
(ball hitting face)
You all right?
Watch the (beep) glasses.
[Conan] And I'll pass it to you.
(beep) (mumbles)
Sorry.
[Ghostly Voice] Sports!
Thanks Conan, back to you!
(catching ball)
(horn)
Ha! All right!
That means it's time for our
Sports Blast NFL Draft Preview
Hot Picks Preview.
I predict The Bangles
will have the first pick.
(whistle)
[Man] That's a foul! Bad Wifi!
Those pics are hot!
And now, it's time for Ref Call Roundup!
[Ghostly Voice] Ref Call Roundup!
(horn)
That means it's time for Ref Call Roundup!
[Ghostly Voice] Ref Call Roundup!
Let's see what cause the reps are making!
Go that way!
Sports!
Hooray!
I have a hat!
Sports!
I'll wait!
And I am a tree!
Sports!
Back to you Conan!
Thanks Andy, back to you.
Thanks Conan, back to you.
Thanks Andy, back to me.
Thanks Conan!
Well, that's all the time we have.
Tune in never again for another episode
of Andy Richter's Sports Blast!
[Ghostly Voice] Sports!
[Man] Andy Richter's Sports Blast!
[Ghostly Voice] Sports! Sports! Sports!